Absolutely nothing
compares to the spectacle
you are about to see.
-I love you. Good luck.
-Love you, too.
Like The Fast and the Furious,
but in real life.
This industrial complex
has been transformed
into ten of the most insane
racecourses ever imagined.
A six-story monstrosity
that will show us
exactly what these drivers
are made of.
My goal
is to show other people...
there are no limits!
Go!
They've come
from across the globe
to chase a dream.
I work about four jobs,
making sure the lights stay on.
It's been
a long road to get here.
When I sit behind the wheel,
I'm not a mom, I'm not a wife...
Oh, my God!
Oh, God!
This is so bad!
If you want something
bad enough,
I don't have a lot of money,
but competition...
that's all that matters
in this life.
Let's go!
Oh, God!